even rogan is a fan of desantis when we
were in jacksonville you know who came
to see him perform so desantis came and
watched him do his comedy show well you
guys were there with us
and then when the fight happened in in
jacksonville guess who came to the fight
the santa and the santa so the went to
the comedy and he went to
the ufc and did you hear what trump said
yesterday do you hear what trump said
you said about the santos what do you
say watch this one you remember just put
trump desantis and go to news what trump
said about desantis yesterday check this
out
trump uh uh uh where he says i actually
can see myself being i think uh desantis
would be a great running mate as a vp oh
yeah oh he said that
go go to that trunk
offered to have him join trump doesn't
rule out running with desantis as his vp
i get along with them because being
negative right now wouldn't work yeah
exactly yeah what do you think what do
you think about that comment like it's
you know i see him as a vp like
how do you process that because okay
let's be uh hey he's the egomaniac we
all know that we're like i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna lie trump was crazy
polarizing whatever the economy all the
policies were good but i mean he does
have a fan base i personally want
desantis to be the president that's just
hands down but if trump runs again trump
could only go for one more term right if
your trump can only go for one more term
i mean why not you're setting up the
santas to you know keep that going for
you know the next for 12 years yeah 12
more years so i mean it could be it
could be good but i mean i i don't from
who do we talk to that time you had here
pat the the girl that was his press
nicki freed or
pushed off the christine when she was
like
it's too early to talk about it she
doesn't she didn't want to mention it
yeah but i felt like she had something
in her pocket where she's like he would
run and he does want to run but i mean i
i think it might be a good strategy to
be like listen i'm definitely going to
go i'm probably going to win because the
way that everything is all jacked up
right now and then you'll just just wait
in the wings and then you'll get
you know i mean you'll get the eight
years after me i think it's an olive
branch he's suddenly saying something
halfway positive about desantis remember
three months ago desantis was
unappreciative that's what trump said
about it remember that and so he was
pushing back like
he was trying to keep him out of the
field of play
three months four months ago now that
he's in the field to play polls for
proving it he's putting out this olive
branch i'm the big dog come run with me
we win
i think that's where it's going i agree
i don't know
um
i think i think trump is still the lead
guy no matter what i think trump trump
dude his endorsement record i don't know
if you're following his endorsement
record he's like 140 and 11. i mean he's
better than the 97 98 chicago bulls the
record he's good
he's 141 and 11 on the endorsements he
made you have to know there's weight
behind his voice
um because look at his camera pat his
campaign not to cut you off his
campaign's gonna be like what did i tell
you look at this [ __ ] you want me maybe
it's that campaign you're right can
actually be i told you so i told you so
right you're and you're correct about
you know how i measure it pat i measure
it that the one that he didn't get in
georgia cnn covered it for three weeks
yeah right this is trump's endorsement
didn't work remember the guy in georgia
and they're like wait a minute why are
they screaming about this one
yeah this one no three weeks no it's
because they're scared to death listen
people can say whatever they want
michelle obama has a voice
with you like michelle obama if michelle
obama goes out there on the campaign
trail
she's got weight when obama shows up
he's got weight when trump shows up he's
got weight i don't care if you like
trump or if you like obama and i don't
care if you don't like them
there is weight behind their voice when
they show up and trump's trump still has
it now trump is claiming he's going to
come out and announce that he's running
this month oh wow he wants to make an
early announcement yeah he wants to make
an early like this month that's going to
be july that's what roger stone said he
was going to do well there's an article
that also came out i don't know if roger
said oh roger said that as well last
week and i project uh that he's going to
say something in july an article just
came out as well that said that not
what's the support in the world he
hasn't pushed back on the polls the
polls with the desantis are going up i
can't let this get to the mid i agree
with that and get and get a decent thank
you
desantis get to ten points over me i
have to declare now to clear the debt
and there and their only thing to kind
of because i remember we we got the
russian collusion thing was for you know
the whole got the whole freaking
presidency the january 16th thing where
is that did that finish i know they had
some girls i think it's still going
they're still going on where they're
like he grabbed the wheel and said let's
go and then all the cnn mini series now
yeah it's it's insane so i mean they
don't really have much on them except
this you know democracy let me tell you
that nobody cares and let's let's talk
about who trump had as his vp before
mike pence mike pence was quiet he stood
in the background he wasn't very loud he
wasn't vocal he was kind of just there
yeah he was around the scientist he had
a fly on his head for like an hour
florida is the hottest state in the
nation right now by far desantis is loud
he's opinionated he's strong in his
beliefs i think mike pence scared the
[ __ ] out of donald trump and i had one
more electoral vote than last time wait
you said i think mike pence scared the
[ __ ] out of him absolutely i don't think
that trump felt that mike pence was loud
enough was vocal enough would defend him
was it really really could stand up for
himself i think trump wants somebody
that's basically like donald trump not
as polarizing but we'll stand up we'll
punch back we'll take the swings we'll
do what has to be done and stand up no
there's a reason that that uh trump
selected mike pence out of nowhere
in 2016. and it's because he was the
exact what do you mean he got him
elected and it got him not an
evangelical base in the midwest he was
very calculated he picked the exact
opposite of him if you recall i'm going
back to 2016. you're probably still in
college then but let me tell you
something
he speci he could have picked christy he
could have picked any number of those
candidates ben carson and he said let me
get the most
white bred middle american
stoic non-drama
like are you saying it was a bad choice
no i'm saying it was a great job i
thought it was a great choice and it's
specifically because he was not
a new yorker trump like christy so what
i'm saying is like i hear what you're
saying in hindsight 2020 he wants
someone a little more bombastic hit back
but the whole like this is the ironic
thing about mike pence
he was the most loyal
boot-licking vice president i've ever
like he was just like you know that's my
present like he was stand by your man
and then the ironic part is you know now
he wants to hang him at the end if you
know your presidential history that's
why nixon chose agnew and that's why
hillary chose quick around the room who
she choose oh who's a weird guy
history is making your point you're
right i agree
the thing that no one wants to talk
about here not here but like
whether you agree with me or not all
good
trump is still talking so here's a
question trump is still toxic desantis
is not toxic so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]